if there was some sort of certification
for getting a jet ski that involved like
making sure that your wife was prepping
her vaginal area you know I think that
would have saved a life and that's all
I'm saying that's all that's my argument
[Music]
but so a husband is being investigated
after a woman dies having her quote
insides ripped out oh my goodness when
falling off of a jet ski oh my God
insides ripped out jet skis be people up
like the propeller fing gutted her so
check this out her name is Elena spab
nailed it from Samara Russia nailed it
she was enjoying a day out on the river
with her husband Ole right know that
he's 52 when the day suddenly took a
turn for the worst he's driving a
highspeed jet ski with a lan of riding
on the back and she fell into the water
he's going like apparently he's going
110 mph [__] yeah wait you 110 on a j
high power oh no no no never mind he's
going 10 miles hour sorry so he's going
10 miles hour right I was like what the
[__] I didn't think that was even
possible I was like is that kilometers
is he going
downhill so uh he was accelerating water
ftle water fle water I can't believe you
guys even talk that for one second so he
he's accelerating right his wife falls
off and then the power of the jet
propulsion afterward caused horrific
wounds power of the jet propulsion but
it's 10 mph so she falls in the water
and her husband hits the gas oh my
goodness at the same time and it shot in
and then she she has Stained a what they
call a hydraulic injury after he created
a water hammer that hit her between the
legs oh he shot her in a py with a jet
propulsion yes he gunned it say that
again but with a WAP Cadence he hit her
in the with a jet propulsion oh [__]
what a bars are you a director holy [__]
[__] was that you really good
enough I heard from coming over here
somewhere as per the health and safety
executive of the region this happens
when the outer lay of the skin is broken
by a jet of fluid Under Pressure which
happened between her legs this is like
it's like those pistol shrimps that like
makes that bul oh yeah but it's like the
life the bigger version the pistol shmp
100 mph force is able to crack the skull
of a cell on a clam fish now say that
with a rra cade in that was legit [__]
I'm not
Joe see Joe has the recall memory
Anthony can't do it stupid dancer brains
can't do it they just danc brain with
his body though he's trying dude he's
trying he could do it with the body but
not the brain yeah not not the brain
bra shout to Anthony
baby uh so so now they're investigating
her husband as potentially like death by
negligence oh she died you can get
charged by that so not only does he have
to [__] mourn her loss but then he's
also GNA be committed damn that's [__]
up that sounds like an honest mistake
though she suffered what they call a
genital rupture which wouldn't have been
as big a deal if her husband had a
bigger dick oh yeah cuz she would have
been stretched out first stretched out
but he had a little ass microp penis she
would have been ready for the situation
but she wasn't at all prepared but if
she was [__] a gorilla dick then she
would have been like easy then then the
hydro pressure wouldn't have then the
hydro pressure according to the
scientific Observer the hydr pressure
wouldn't had big of an impact on her in
membrane and that's what happened if she
was masturbating with a fire hydrant
easy exactly easy if she had just been
using like one of those big elans like
just between her legs then she probably
would have survived the incident
according to the coroner I
know that's what the autopsy report said
according to the
cor oh my God I can't believe that that
that's a fatal [__] it is yeah yeah
and the corner recommends by the way if
you're out there just prepare prep
yourself the corner recommends if you're
going to be on a jet ski he says prepare
yourself get the Black Mamba right A lot
of these different things you get on
Amazon right now $3 $45 not dark KN the
dark KN Dark Knight but you have to work
your way up black m it's like gauges of
a earring though you can't just go
straight to [__] 14in with a [__]
3in circumference it's got to you got to
you got to get your bachel before you
get your master right right right who
would have thought at the end of that
it's just a SEO
thece but yeah that's what the corner
says he says it's heartbreaking that she
just didn't stretch herself out enough
to be ready for this situation I I feel
like I need he's never seen a more
heartbreaking situation I feel like I
need more context in a sense of like was
he like trying to like get rid of her
anyway it's like it could happen so fast
do you think well the husband said she
was a pretty big [__] when she was
while she was
alive that doesn't like was she like the
air to some [__] throne in some some
country and she had like millions of
dollars to her name but because they got
you know what I mean yeah I know what
you're saying but I feel like negligence
is more like you guys went jet skiing
and then your wife is on the jet ski and
you're drinking and then you didn't even
look back once in 30 minutes and you
look back you're like oh [__] she's not
even there what the [__] did she go yeah
that's negligence no that's an accident
Joe but then what about this then
[__] [__] skedaddling while she's
[__] riding it in the back another rap
line jeez we don't have to go there but
I'm just saying another
be cool sounds good cuz I'm just
imagining her all right she's like like
that right and then he goes and then she
falls and then as she falls back down
and splashes he goes let it rip and then
so her legs are spread and it [__]
shoots her out into the air to be honest
it is hard to to notice somebody falling
off the jet ski when you're going yeah
it's hard yeah yeah the way that this
paints it it's like she falls off and he
looks at her and he
goes yeah W leg and then she goes C side
yeah W legs are spread that don't work
like that it work like that maybe for
this to be a negligence charge it really
is a little bit more of a like you got
to really [__] up to make this happen
yeah like it's impossible to normally do
this type of thing you think cuz people
be falling J Skies every day or is it
mainly because of the fact that it went
through her genital area well that's
what I mean maybe like maybe it didn't
happen as fast as we're imagining it
like if this happened to her ankle and
she like had to amputate from like her
KNE
if only we saved your life but it's
almost like this guy's getting punished
for being dumb it's like your honor is
it a crime to being stupid being
punished for being extra extra if I
can't drink a [__] AP pack and drive
on a a CD is this America and like this
is Russia he's like okay my bad Maybe
This falls into like a like an indirect
tier of cruel and unusual punishment
because death by whatever like a car
accident or whatever that's one thing
but like death by like ruptured vagina
you know what I mean it just goes into a
whole different category with the entire
it was like oh maybe it's so gruesome
huh that it's just hitting too hard but
that usually means that they were gross
incompetence right or like there was
there was like a lot of dumbassery going
on that it was like you were you're it's
it's cuz you're lazy people W out on
Jess though yeah that's what it's meant
to be like you are meant to just kind of
mess around you go nuts you hit manties
all kinds of [__] you don't care it's
about you out there it's about you you
use a [__] starfish for a ramp that's
that's it star fish for a ramp right got
some air huh you know if you can catch a
little bit of Glide off of that thing
that's what you're going to do that's
what you're going to do you'll be like
I'm Coming For You Patrick you think
they're going to court with this though
and they're like exhibit day and they
bring out like these [__] photos on
Old School projector and the jury has to
endure like seeing Oh God that sucks you
know what I'm saying I do think that
because I think like verbage enough is
already like whoa what happened and then
when it's not even left to your
imagination cuz you're getting [__]
visual reference well also it depends on
how this dude is reacting in court
imagine when they the jury's like oh and
then he's just like what she's like so
every single time they say vagina or
maybe it was his testimony that made it
like you [__] stupid if you open if
you maybe yeah maybe he had a bad
deposition when they were like what went
on he's like I don't know bados fell off
I gunned it it does sound stupid soon as
she fell off that son [__] I said holy
[__] I can get enough 5 10 [__] miles
hour let's [__] go we just got a
little faster I didn't realize cuz I as
soon as she got on that thing I said
honey you you should stay back at the
beach and she said no I want to go out H
I want to go out I said oh my [__]
God here we go every time I've been on a
jet ski or rented one at a place I've
never had them say a warning that this
could even happen at all they're not
like hey if the person in the back falls
off just stop they don't say that well
not a lot of people do the reading but
don't they tell you the directions the
Lev of that or that yeah they do but
they've never they've never said like oh
there's a risk of [__] turning a
person's vagina inside out yeah bro what
the [__] or that it would be fatal in
that way a hydraulic injury I had fun
flipping one too you ever flip one did
you flip one you hit the wave and and it
goes like that and then and it f it goes
upside down and then you're supposed to
get on and grab one side and then pull
like this while you go underwater [__]
but I was too small I did that on N64
wave racing
baby does it feel like it has some crazy
pickup when you when you hell yeah R
absolutely so it's scary I I'm still
going to make the Assumption in my own
head based on the Corner's information
that's very accurate that a lot of this
probably just comes down to precedence
you know what I mean like the fact that
there is none for like vaginal
destruction that it's so like yeah it's
so crazy that they need the the
punishment to just exist in such a way
that's like matching it but he lost his
wife isn't that punishment enough unless
he wanted her
gone that's what the corer said well
look as a as a as a you know I again I'm
a certified scuba diver you you learn
things about how to deal with situations
right how to deal with emergency
emergency situations right like if if
there was some sort of certification for
getting a jet ski that involved like
making sure that your wife was prepping
her vaginal area you know I think that
would have saved life and that's all I'm
saying that's all that's argument
females need to get gaping just get
ready out there practice ready out there
before they go R my wife will never go
on to Jet what would happen to a woman
that was properly gaped yeah in the same
well think about like this she's as soon
as she hits the water she's already
folded
up so now now add 10,000 PBS of
pressure they need to practice being a
water balloon and now you may me
understand what I'm talking about
actually [__]
[Music]
h